foreign
good morning everyone members of the ENA
committee and guess who are joining us
we are here for our final exec session
of the 2122
legislative session and uh I want to
thank you all for coming
we've got uh seven bills that we have to
make recommendations on today so I don't
believe this will take a long time but I
certainly appreciate you all making the
trip here and joining us
foreign
all right I think we are ready to just
get right into it any announcements
Peter that you have before we go
uh no I think that uh
the only thing that was going to be
happening that didn't was the uh tour of
unh and we're going to try to do that
early in next session so it's not sort
of an afterthought
awesome
all right we're gonna open up House Bill
366 defining Animal Hoarding and I will
look to representative Bixby for a
motion
I move that we do not recommend
366776 366 for further legislation do I
have a second
I'll second it representative come to us
seconds
I will open it up for discussion and
I'll recognize representative Bixby
uh the prime sponsor of the bill has
said that he does not feel that this
needs to go forward uh and uh
in our hearings on this we had several
hearings on this and we got more and
more information saying that this was a
very hard not to crack and that it
probably does not have a solution using
this pathway
well as Prime sponsor of the bill I
guess I will speak on it for a minute
but well said uh excuse me a little frog
in my throat today
no we you know we certainly felt I think
I speak for the committee we feel this
is an important topic but
we were not able to find what we felt
was a good solution to the problems that
we identified and you know as
representative Bixby said to
seems like we were going to create more
problems than we were going to solve by
continuing on with it so I I'm glad we
had the conversation I certainly may
look at the bill in the future of you
know bringing it back or someone else
may because the topic is very important
but we'll uh at this time we as a
committee didn't just didn't have a
solution to it so we felt it was best
not to recommend it
any further discussion
representative Stapleton thank you Mr
chair
I think that bill was going in the right
direction I think we have a problem with
Admiral Animal Hoarding
um but uh too many problems unanswered
questions
um I think we ought to look at it for
the next term
well we can certainly do that if someone
wants to bring it back to life again
anyone else
seeing none I will ask the clerk to call
a roll so just for clarification today
we're only going to there'll be one of
two recommendations either we recommend
it for future legislation or we do not
recommend it it's just a straight up and
down vote there's no amendments there's
no edits and there'll be one committee
report if there is a situation where we
have a minority there's no Minority
Report it's just an a committee report
on the recommendation
perhaps understable so so the the motion
is not recommended for future
legislation is that right correct thank
you
representative Bixby so just one other
note on that uh the whether we recommend
or do not recommend for future
legislation that does not bind a future
legislature in any way whatsoever so if
someone decides that they actually want
to pick up one of the things we Rec we
don't recommend uh that there's no
problem with that
foreign
anyone else
all right I will ask the clerk to call
the roll
voting on HB 366 not recommended for
future legislation representative yes
representative verville
representative Arnold
representative Stapleton yes
representative hamola
yes
representative Mason yes representative
Sanborn
represent Bixby yes representative Dotsy
yes yes representative Murray yes
representative Von plinski yes
uh Mr chair yes
12-0 motion passes all right so we have
voted not to recommend Health Bill 366
for future legislation
okay next we will open up House Bill 438
relative to the confidentiality of
animal records databases and I will look
to representative Bixby for a motion
I recommend that we do not recommend for
further legislation
do I have a second
made reference under the Bon polinski
seconds
excuse me I will recognize
representative Bixby to speak to his
motion so this was um a bill to add uh
or to make sure that there was security
added to the animal records database
which uh was passed in the
um
budget uh last year and uh the basically
all of the recommendations for
um for security that were suggested in
this bill were included in the budget
version so I think that this is we have
it pretty much covered
any further comments
representative I somehow knew I was
going to be calling on let's see as I am
the sponsor of this bill
should say a few words so although the
bill that passed for the animal database
does include a lot of the safety and
privacy protocols I think it's inherent
upon this committee to make sure that
those
are actually done and if we need to be I
will be bringing forth or ask someone to
bring forth legislation if needed to
ensure those privacies
any further comments
seeing none we are voting on House Bill
438 relative to the confidentiality of
animal records databases with the motion
of we do not recommend future
legislation and I will ask the clerk to
call the roll
yes representative Davis yes
representative Stapleton yes represent
hamola yes representative Mason yes
representative Sanborn yes represent
Bixby yes
representative dutse yes represent
Murray yes representative Von plitzki
yes
uh Mr chair yes 12-0 motion passes all
right so we have
recommended House Bill 438 not
recommended for future legislation with
a vote of 12 to zero
next we will do House Bill 585 FN
allowing the prepayment of dog licenses
licensing fees for the duration of a
rabies vaccination and reducing fines
related there too and I will look to
representative Bixby for a motion
I recommend that we I move that we
recommend not to have for the
legislation
do we have a second
representative Dusty seconds
representative Bixby you're recognized
to speak to your motion so uh the idea
was that because rabies shots last for
three years it might be possible to have
dog licenses last for that amount of
time and uh we got a very lukewarm
response at best from all of the city
and Municipal clerks all the municipal
clerks that we had approached about this
uh and what we don't want to do is make
more work for the municipal clerks so it
seems like this is probably best to just
leave things as they are
and I know I have spoken with the prime
sponsor on this bill and uh you know
they're while the concept is good they
recognize the concerns that were there
and they may look in the future to try
and address some of those concerns but
they were fine with the committee making
this recommendation now
any further comments
seeing none uh I will ask the clerk to
call the roll on House Bill 585 with a
recommendation of not recommended for
future legislation
okay so HP 585 FN not recommended
representative comtwa yes representative
verville yes representative Davis yes
representative Stapleton yes
representative mola yes
representative Mason yes representative
samboy represent Bixby yes
representative yes representative Murray
yes represent Von plinski yes Mr chair
yes 12-0
all right with a world of twelve to zero
we have moved not recommended for a
future
legislation on House Bill 585.
next we will do House Bill 627
establishing evaluated Grant matching
fund for New Hampshire agricultural
producers and I will look to
representative Bixby for a motion I move
that we do not recommend for further
legislation
representative Bixby moves not
recommended for future legislation do I
have a second representative come to our
seconds representative Bixby you're
recognized yeah so this is my bill and I
basically picked it up from a bill that
uh was held was an interim study
the previous term and I uh
so I didn't really know the subject
matter all as well as I might have and
uh when I got into looking at the the
details of it it looked like the
uh the numbers in it were just not
correct and the uh and the mechanism was
not correct and uh the the basic idea
was that people who are applying for
value-added Grants from USDA should have
some access to a little bit more
resources to help make that the match
that's necessary for that uh that's a
laudable goal but I don't think that
anything in this bill uh is something
that's going to work for making to to
achieve that goal so I think we you know
if if someone else somewhere wants to
come back with a bill that it aimed at
that goal that's fine but I think we
we're done with this one
any further comments from the committee
seeing none
I will ask the clerk to call the roll on
House Bill 627 with a recommendation of
not recommended for future legislation
-fm-a not recommended representative yes
representative yes representative Davis
yes representative Stapleton yes
representative pomola yes represent
Mason yes Representative Sam Bowen yes
representative Bixby yes representative
dutse yes represent Murray yes
representative Von plinsky yes Mr chair
yes 12-0 the vote is 12-0 we have moved
not recommended for future legislation
on House Bill 627.
next we will do House Bill 1111
establishing a commission to study
extended producer responsibility so we
had subcommittee meetings on this
particular Bill we actually did a study
on it and I'm going to call on
representative Murray who chaired the
subcommittee to bring the results from
that committee and and I want to thank
you for sharing that committee this year
I know that you had a few bills that
were put through there and I want to
thank you and all all of the committee
members that served on that subcommittee
I think you all did a great job
thank you um yes so to to briefly just
um if I may
um the subcommittee met twice the first
was an informal listening session where
we heard from various stakeholders and
that came forward we heard from uh Des
who uh still
um suggests in their Solid Waste plan
that they do they would like to see
extended producer responsibility
integrated into some of the things that
they see within their in in the
department of environmental science or
Services excuse me as well as the
listening session revealed a widespread
desire to continue working on the
pressures that our waste streams have at
varying levels of the government whether
it was Municipal
um and local levels or at the state
level we also saw uh continue to hear
about
um increases in tipping fees that were
creating pressures on municipalities
since 2019
those have continually increased and it
was also noted that we still have no
materials recovery facility or Murph in
the state of New Hampshire and so with
that there was some discussion about the
expediency with which committees can
move versus commissions and we heard
some testimony and thoughts around that
and
um then in our
work session the following week we
continue to have that discussion about
how we felt that that made work to our
advantage to have a committee doing the
work versus a commission so with that
there was a unanimous agreement that it
should move forward for future
legislation perhaps with a a study
committee looking at extended producer
responsibility with a lens towards 149 m
so with that that's where we're at
all right so we have a recommendation
from the subcommittee representative
Bixby would you like to comment yeah um
another aspect of this is that extended
producer responsibility is a fairly
complicated complicated undertaking and
requires aligning multiple stakeholders
and it's uh sufficiently complicated
that just doing a bill right now to do
it is probably not going to get the kind
of results that we want whereas a study
committee can pull in various
stakeholders and help figure out a way
that is agreeable to
um to the entire stakeholder population
to go forward with it
representative Murray did you actually
move the bill for
so I would like to speak
her uh
okay sorry I I missed it when you said
that so do I have a second on that
representative uh come to our second so
make sure I get my process in order
yes representative verbal thank you Mr
chairman
um
the challenge that I have with this is
we have an ever-growing Patchwork of
extended producer responsibility laws
state by state uh across this country
and that Patchwork of of laws is
creating a very large burden on a lot of
companies that now have to track and and
participate in these programs state by
state this is an issue in my opinion
that really should be delegated up to
the federal level what we need if if we
need as a nation an extended producer
responsibility uh type of program it
should be a federal one so that it's
uniform from coast to coast right now
you you have companies that are
supplying into two to 50 states and now
having to comply with this Patchwork of
legislation and it's for that reason
that I will not vote in favor to
recommend a commission to to study Erp
in New Hampshire thank you Mr chairman
representative Contour
the chair we are not recommending a
commission we're only recommending a
study committee to study a very narrow
section of the law which is 149-m
and I do understand what you're saying
um so
the prime sponsor was also okay with us
changing it from a commission to a study
committee so that in our in the ENA
whoever's on that committee next year
can really do a deep dive and then
possibly recommend to the federal
delegation
Mr chairman
representative yeah thank you
representative Cromwell I I did misspeak
um and I apologize for that I do know
it's a committee and I I appreciate the
the correction
um but it it doesn't change my My
overall position but thank you thank you
Mr chairman representative hamola
add that um I had concerns as well this
was something that we discussed I do
feel like that we have the framework
that we need already in which to look at
this issue and study it if we wanted to
if it's as it's
um was communicated to us a priority
then we already have those structures
that can do that through subcommittees
so I had some issues with recommending
that on its own the one thing that
um that I appreciated though is rep
comptwa came up with the solution of
really looking at this isn't so much a
standalone for uh extended extended
responsibilities as much as it's to see
how that fits in with current RSA 149
and the waste reduction goals so because
it's within that vein that I felt
comfortable moving forward but I do feel
like we already have enough venues in
which to discuss this topic thank you
any further discussion
representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair I hear well uh
representative verville's concern
relative to the heavy load put on by any
number of states on producers and that's
a cost factor and that gets passed on to
the consumer and the products
however because
this bill is narrow focus on a study
committee I think it deserves at least
some further consideration
whether it goes one way or the other not
to Prejudice it but I think the
committee might be useful to either
perfect it or put it to sleep once and
for all
representative dutzie yes thank you I'm
chairman I just need some clarification
because the the bill was to establish a
commission okay and there's no
amendments that we that are allowed here
so does the study committee
recommendation override what's actually
in this bill and so we are voting for a
study committee and not a commission
when you want to take uh representative
Bixby yeah so
um this was clarified by
um by our our committee researcher and
also
um uh by sort of a second by uh sort of
by second boy you know one step and
removed also by the uh clerk that when
one is recommending for future
legislation one is essentially
recommending the idea rather than the
text of the bill
representative Murray
thank you and I'd like to just speak to
uh representative verbal I appreciate
your um your thoughts on the issue and
and one of the things that I would like
to say is that we definitely recognize
that there are
um between states there are unique
differences in how whether it's product
stewardship or extended producer
responsibility are put together between
states and that is that is in part part
of the reason why we think that future
study is recommended to some degree so I
do appreciate your um your thoughts
around the the matter and I really am
grateful for the conversation that we've
had around this I think we worked as a
subcommittee extremely hard to come to a
consensus on this so thank you
I just want a note for the record there
was an error in the bill actually it
actually listed as both a study
committee and then a commission as well
so in the bill itself we discarded an
error that the um Bill sponsor was not
aware of and so the bill technically
says both
Senate Bixby
so uh one of the things that we learned
uh in the uh soil conditioner study
committee was that there is actually a
National Organization that
provides model legislation for all
um for all states on the definitions and
practices for use with fertilizer so uh
and this is this is a
um this is a non-governmental
organization that does this so it is
possible to achieve uh goals across
states without having it to be done by
the federal level one of the things that
I think that we would that the study
committee would need to look into is
what Avenues are there out there in the
in the private world that uh could help
move forward epr and make that regular
across uh all across all states so that
uh states are referring to one body of
ideas and that is something that would
probably
have to come forward from the industry
so I think that
and we one of the one reason to study is
we don't know exactly what's out there
in terms of that yet or whether there
are things that are being developed and
that's something that needs to be
studied
representative burrville thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Bixby I
I agree with you on what you just said
the disconnect is what what you're
suggesting in my opinion is more
appropriately handled at the federal
level to talk to Industries about
National standards for both product
stewardship and extended producer
responsibility because right now what we
have is this Patchwork of states that
are defining things differently they're
including things that other states
aren't other states are including things
some states aren't and even when you get
a quote unquote National recommendation
once it comes down to the state level
it's up to the state to decide what they
want to do and every state likes to have
a unique solution that they believe best
suits the needs of of their citizens
their communities in their states and
that's how we wind up with with
patchworks that then Industries have to
comply with another example is that
we've got a lot of States Maine being
the most recent which has passed
legislation relative to the inclusion of
pfas inside of products
so that we're talking about chemically
bound things so is it is it found in in
Plastics right is it an additive to
Plastics is an added to that not not not
free roaming pfas like we've had issues
with um in Southern New Hampshire and
other locations right so so now
industry is getting flooded with emails
do the products that you make do the
products that you supply
conform to the main state law Maine is
not the only one doing this these Erp
programs are the same thing they are but
it's a different topic it's not specific
to people's but it becomes the same
thing it these things become onerous and
burdensome when they become state by
state
that's why I can't support it because it
should be kicked up in my opinion to the
federal level so that we have a National
Standard thank you Mr Speaker all right
Mr chairman hey I don't want that job no
I know that's not the one you're loving
for
representative control thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative
verville for your concerns
sit on another study committee where we
were looking at the Disposable flushable
wipes and labeling laws and in that
study committee
um our final report we're supposed to
meet Friday but our final report is to
send information to the federal
legislation and say this is must should
be done at the federal level so
a study committee can actually formulate
that and and send it to the federal
delegation and get it to people to make
them aware uh because like you said on
that particular issue that we're
discovering there's all these different
laws in all these different states and
so I agree with you and I appreciate
your comments
any further
discussion
representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair um
sometimes
we have these issues which are complex
and intricate and they need several
terms or several iterations to sort out
and develop a body and knowledge
and I think this is one of them
especially with representative Orville's
good point about pfas and products and
that's a hot button issue of much
concern now
we have office of legislative services
that could be very helpful and
instrumental and to the study committee
on this however it goes but to develop
the information a bit further for a
better decision even if this is only
step three out of four or five so I'm in
support of the rfl thank you any further
discussion
seeing none I think I'll wrap it up with
just saying this is the one thing that I
appreciate about this committee is we
can sit and have a very respectful and
thoughtful conversation with everyone
presenting you know their opinions and
and I just very much appreciate it I've
been very fortunate to chair this
committee and you all are great
okay so the motion we have on the table
on House Bill 1111 is to recommend it
for future legislation so I'm going to
call on the uh calling the clerk to call
the roll and
thank you Mr chair HB 1111 recommended
for future legislation representative
yes representative verbal no
representative Davis
representative Stapleton yes
representative yes represent Mason yes
representative samboy
representative Bixby yes represent
dutzie
representative Murray yes representative
Von plinsky yes Mr chair yes 11-1
so whether 11 to 1 recommendation to
recommend for future legislation on
House Bill 1111.
next we'll do House Bill 1121 relative
to new solid waste sites now Colin and
recommend excuse me I'll call on
representative Bixby for a motion
I move that we do not recommend this
bill for further legislation
representative Bixby moves we do not
recommend it for future legislation do I
have a second
representative
I will call on representative Bixby to
speak to his motion this bill would have
required a substantial bond for on for
any new uh landfill construction and the
mechanisms of doing that Bond were not
very clear uh the amount of the bond how
that was determined was not very clear
and whether this would have actually
achieved the goal of making sure that
um
that Latin that a new landfill owner
would not have wouldn't uh be fully
capable of cleaning up any mess that
happened was also not clear uh this is
probably not the right mechanism for
getting at the goal
um and uh so that uh
the uh this is so I it
is not a good way to continue forward
thank you any further discussion
foreign
motion to not recommend for future
legislation on House Bill 1121 and I
will ask the clerk to call the roll
thank you Mr chair HB 1121 not
recommended representative yes
representative verbal yes representative
Davis yes representative Stapleton yes
representative yes representative Mason
representative Sanborn represent Bixby
yes represent dutse yes represent Murray
yes represent Von plinski yes Mr chair
yes 12-0
and the 12-0 vote we will have voted to
not recommend future legislation on
House Bill 1121.
all right this is our final bill
1652 relative to the recycling of
Beverage containers and I will look to
representative Bixby for a motion uh I
reck I move that we recommend not to con
uh consider not to recommend further
legislation
representative Bixby moves not to
recommend future legislation do we have
a second representative come to us
seconds representative Bixby would you
like to speak to your motion yes so this
bill uh is was essentially an attempt to
graft a bottle bill from I believe Rhode
Island onto New Hampshire law and it was
the mechanisms of it were extremely
complex and uh it did not uh
whether or not you believe in Bottle
bills in general this was nowhere near
the right way to do it and uh the
um the sense that I heard was that
um it probably if we are if we want to
encourage beverage container recycling
uh further than uh that's something that
would be best done with more
um industry involvement in designing a
plan for recovering beverage containers
which would fit under the rubric of epr
and we're having a study committee for
that uh or we're recommending a study
committee for that so
um
so going ahead with this as a standalone
Bill probably doesn't make sense
any further discussion
seeing none
we are we have a motion to not recommend
for future legislation on House Bill
1652 and I will ask the clerk to call
the roll thank you Mr chair
hb1652-n not recommended representative
comtwa yes representative vervo yes
representative Davis yes representative
Stapleton yes represent pamola yes
represent Mason representative Sanborn
representative Bixby yes represented
dutzie represent Murray yes represent
Von plinsky no
and Mr chair yes eleven one
all right so we with uh 11-1 the
committee has voted not to recommend
future legislation on House Bill 1652.
well we've done it we've made it through
our two-year session and I just I want
to thank all of you for the opportunity
to be your chair it's been a pleasure
you've been a great committee to work
with and I just I I'm I have the best
Committee in the house I tell every
other chair that there may be some
disagreement but uh I know I'm right
[Laughter]
representative Bixby yes I'd like to
thank chairman Pearl for his leadership
over the last two years uh one of the
things that I have appreciated in my
tenure on this committee and I think I'm
actually the longest standing person of
the committee is a real commitment to
nonpartisan work on the issues of the
committee and I think that chairman
Pearl has been really exemplary in
following through on that uh tradition
and commitment
thank you
any other thoughts and comments
representative Stapleton thank you Mr
chair I'm I've enjoyed working on on
this committee
um and I really appreciate the
bipartisan a rapport and cooperation
um really effective uh and pleasurable
to work with you all thank you
anyone else
representative dutzie
I would just like to say I mean I think
the
um what we the collegiality that we have
experienced on this committee really
comes from the leadership and I
appreciate the fact that representative
Bixby and representative Pearl have been
able to work together and work out a lot
of these things so that for members at
least in our caucus we really feel that
when when we're discussing bills that
the leadership has really thought about
it done their homework and brought
um some structure and Leadership to us
for us to think about and so it really
does start at the top and I really
appreciate the leadership from both the
ranking member and the chair of this
committee
thank you anyone else
well I wanna I wanna Echo that same
sentiment because uh representative
Bixby has been a pleasure to work with
and you all have you know we've done a I
believe we've done really good work here
in our committee while we may not have
always agreed I think in the end we've
always put out very thoughtful uh
recommendations to the house floor and
and I always appreciated the very
thoughtful
um committee reports that all of you
drafted I had very little edits that I
ever had to do and I can tell you from
talking with some of my other chairs
that was not the case in every committee
so I appreciate that you made my job
look very easy and uh and uh it's just
it is appreciated
I'm gonna let you all go with only one
one thing I ask maybe is that we could
all get together and just do a quick
picture if we could have someone before
we take off it'd be nice I I won't be
back here next year as all of you or
most of you probably know I'm I'm not
running for the house again I'm looking
to run for receipt in the Senate
if I get there I'll look forward to
working with all of you that are back
and for those of you who aren't coming
back I'm not sure exactly where
everybody is we appreciate your service
and look forward to another great
session and
23 and 24 and it'll keep up the good
work if I am successful in getting on
the Senate side please know my door is
always open to all of you and I mean
that both sides of the aisle it's uh the
conversations and the relationships that
we have made in this committee are
invaluable to me and I look forward to
having those in the future so
with that I'm going to close the
committee I believe we can actually
adjourn can't we since this is our last
act we typically can't but I'm going to
adjourn the session for the environment
and agricultural committee for the for
this session and thank you all
beautiful